welcome to world stories im sue me so
Miss Conda and this is your
international reporters magazine coming
up we rev up our engines with a couple
of creative tour guides in croatia we
dive into the deep blue sea to take a
closer look at an underwater Museum in
Mexico and ever heard of the trop e we
take a trip down memory lane with a cult
object from behind the Iron Curtain all
that and more coming up but first the
Tunisian revolution triggered a wave of
political and social change across the
Arab world that came to be referred to
as the Arab Spring it was young
Tunisians in particular who took to the
streets in demand of democracy and
better opportunities but three years on
not much has changed the country has
been crippled by political turmoil the
economy has failed to stabilize and
unemployment especially among young
adults is high that's prompted some
Tunisian to get creative and break
boundaries too in our first story Ahmed
Al alcuni of tienen takes us to the
south of the country where two sisters
are challenging long-standing traditions
isfahan and Iman are sisters their
father passed away and left him his
motorcycle repair shop they needed to
make a living so they broke with
long-standing social norms and ventured
into a traditionally male domain little
kid my heavy my sister and I learned how
to do this from our Father he was
getting on in years and would help him
at work my dad yet the motto Mackenzie
school near owner their father left no
other financial security for his family
when he passed on it was the only way
the girls had to earn money at the White
Oaks they defend my sister Eman often
held our Father art so she learned a lot
more from him than I did and did she go
my father didn't have a son to help him
but I was at his side from earliest
childhood so I learned the skills I
needed to take over the workshop or
later my sister asked Mahan joined me
panel budget of tenaya isfahan and Iman
take turns in the shop one of them works
on fixing engines while the other takes
care of the household and their aging
mother now the two sisters are known all
through the town as the fighters
labadie gb solid or is it none of your
idea that Sunday repair motorcycles yes
really more fulfilling said the
hospitality they put lots of effort into
finding the right spare parts for their
customers minus blaze smoothly Madonsela
miss la frontera yeah hello the two
women have drawn a lot of attention from
people in the area both positive and
negative some critics don't like to see
women breaking into traditionally male
professions
should do we met him godini the two
girls work with great commitment and
they dedicate themselves to repairing
those motorcycles they serve as an
example of how young people are
committing themselves to making an
honest living in every kind of business
Demi sail the ship it but she's had that
and they're fighting against
unemployment vittala we care for her
children iodine in lahaina jarabe these
two women have faced many challenges and
invested a lot of willpower and patients
into their business to preserve their
financial independence
but she is terrible fear many people are
surprised to see what we do when we're
fixing motorcycles our hands get dirty
and greasy but that doesn't bother us
let me call FEMA never a new breed of
women fighters is appearing in Tunisia
women who are facing the economic
challenges and adapting to meet them
women who are breaking out of
traditional roles imposed on them by
their society while Ozma Han and Iman
fix up bikes the two women in our next
story know just how to use them we meet
Magdalena and Lana who have built a
thriving tourism business in Croatia
with the help of their trusty
motorcycles the idea is to provide
visitors and insiders guide to their
country and it's proven to be a success
marina gov renovage from HRT has more
Magdalena and Lana are anything but
typical promoters of local tourist
attractions it all began when Magdalena
unable to find a job decided to turn her
love of motorcycles and new technology
into a novel business concept together
with her friend lana the two of them
created motorcycle postcards boys emo
society we ride together and spend time
together and we thought of something
unique that's easy to do there wasn't
much snow in Croatia last winter so he
rode to a different location almost
every weekend we took walks and did a
lot of sightseeing during the day and we
went out at night and it made perfect
sense to us to put it all together in a
post card stock where Adam oh sweet oh
okay on a cello mojo mosaic lapita
kokkonen spada
within just a few months the e tourist
platform was born
it gives tourists insights into
everything Croatia has to offer beyond
the usual attractions
studies show that new media is the first
thing foreign tourists turn to when
they're looking for a holiday
destination sajan equal this denied
these are means we're taking it one step
further by providing tourists with
direct contact to the people in
beautiful locations in Croatia Oh
Jeanette waters for ble okay some tours
went from tavern to tavern from warrants
a little wine cellar and people loved it
no one had offered them that before
normal tour guides don't do that
comedian they take tourists to the
cathedral and so on but we show them
what's really on offer here where we go
ourselves one time we got lost and
stumbled on a seafood restaurant that
served fresh seafood literally caught
that morning there was prosciutto cheese
and olive oil but a kind of stuff
tourists love it's a unique approach
showing what life is really like from an
authentic perspective
you
tourists can even see what it's like to
go out and eat and mix with the locals
you
epidemic support as far as natural
beauty is concerned Croatia is without a
doubt a beautiful country it's academic
picasa to this local beauty can be found
everywhere but how can you do more than
just show people the beautiful
countryside how can you get them to come
back again our idea was to bring people
together and that is what we have to
offer through us people get to know
local farmers and the owners of small
hotels and inns that gives people a
reason to come back again because once
you've had a wonderful time staying
somewhere you're sure to return da bomb
nyagra me change forget everything you
know about croatia let lana and
magdalena take you off the beaten path
and give you the real picture of life in
this southern european country
Mao Zedong was China's Communist Party
Chairman from its founding in 1949 until
his death in 1976 during that time
chairman mao instituted a series of what
many consider disastrous policies as he
tried to introduce a Chinese style of
communism with an iron fist his cultural
and economic programs resulted in
widespread death and suffering in our
next story to reporters Luke we and
elisabeth shue share a very personal
story of mccoy's own grandparents li hui
fang and djuan gen and the hardships
they endured under Chairman Mao's rain
the allegiance times are so hard come on
you have to count every penny just to
get by gamma Google Tommy in addition to
the cost of groceries we had expenses
for other things like clothes not the
ladder too gaudy to meet you mark it was
expensive to have clothes made a little
but even more expensive to buy new
clothes so I started learning how to sew
our own clothing the guts are you lying
ah yes got to I also made my own shoes
what can they learn to cut hair there
Duncan person will see elevati I learned
how to do all that on my own sky little
now will you there but look I'll show
you some of the photos it's at this one
shows your mama and your two uncles it's
at what the law not go in that one you
can see me with your grandfather goes
outside here's a group photo of the
whole family good sort of saw pieces you
can tell these photos are from the
Cultural Revolution look what stands out
about these photos everyone was wearing
a pin of Chairman Mao back then everyone
had to wear them be more tears yatza
donor and Guam now it's hard to imagine
what was going on in this country back
then Matthew the the cushy on Jana pure
girl for example at the main entrance at
work we had to bow in front of Mars
portrait and salute and yell long live
Chairman Mao Julie here more out of your
work we had to salute miles portray
together Lee you Lissa more today and
you imagine that look it's all day I
can't at universal balance felucca in
1958 your grandfather got hit by the
anti rightist campaign he'd be they
labeled him a right us to Center we
suffered for that for 20 years maddinson
King Leela I son you ain't else y'all
tis
it's nice and sunny this afternoon isn't
it don't laugh you know that from court
that coming the cultural revolution
affected people all over the country
here in Shanghai to the fool there are
you it's rich farmers
counter-revolutionaries rogues writers
and intellectuals normal me not either
the farmers it might have been a little
better but the farmers were hit by what
they called pulling out white flags
fizzle Ricky yes Canyon if any farmer
wines but that's why nearly every family
has hit
12 of my bosses committed suicide in
yellow I've been falsely accused and
couldn't cope with the situation some
drown themselves others jumped off to
all buildings listen no Holy See xin li
Shang with the situation like it was
deep down I wasn't happy isn't he I
didn't put your grandfather under any
additional psychological pressure well
uncle but now papa I'm not my children
your mother and uncles either that's you
you a little kanmani noon you sure cuz
she always been our ally Jonathan your
grandfather was sent to the country to
do physical labor do I let me think that
was really hard you had to carry heavy
loads I suffered along with your
grandfather yes or that you're that
namibia the chi Chi his shoulders was
falling in Syria would you nip so I
sewed shoulder pads for him out of old
clothes killing me by lone woman I'd
seen that in a movie wow that you're
such a key farmers had these pads on
their shoulders no me with that plot
theater the book I used to call them
shoulder pads oh yeah me like as a polar
here will you show you teach it Tiruchy
column then your grandfather shoulders
didn't bleed anymore Lord o Allah Moana
cui Xia mood today at ica put no my hips
don't hurt anymore I used to hurt every
time I stood up
chupa a year after 1978 of course things
changed a lot your grandfather got his
old job back later we're for he got an
even better job with your finger silken
call a console he was happier mahima and
the whole family was happy along with
all happy thanks to Luke way for sharing
that story with us now if you're
visiting europe paris london rome or
anywhere really there's a pretty good
chance you'll visit a museum they house
many of the world's most valuable
collections whether it's art or history
or science on display now imagine this
what if you could visit a museum
underwater it is possible right in the
middle of the cancun national marine
park in mexico life-sized art sits on
the ocean floor Isaac cosas waconia from
Mexico News Network takes us into the
blue it's about the race of people how
we are continuously changing and
evolving
once these get put into the sea they're
going to be completely inundated with
fish with live corals with the sponges
and the aim of it is to turn
into a great artificial reef
it's an encounter with the most precious
hidden treasure in the Mexican Caribbean
Sea an artistic display of emotions that
amazes visitors with its portrayal of
humankind's evolution culture identity
and the longing to preserve the
environment the underwater Museum of Art
better known as Musa is considered by
the Google Cultural Institute as one of
the 95 most important museums in the
world and the largest underwater
attraction the pristine and turquoise
waters of the Caribbean host more than
500 permanent life-size sculptures that
also function as an artificial coral
reef and home to thousands of exotic
marine species
you
moussa extends over a natural protected
area called the west coast national park
of isla mujeres Punta Cancun and Punta
new zouk located between Cancun and Isla
Mujeres it has gained great popularity
in recent years drawing more than
750,000 visitors from all over the world
visitors marvel at the sight of such
impressive art musa also serves the
purpose of creating an artificial
habitat for the area's ecosystem
revealing a colorful and exotic
underwater world each sculpture is made
with environmentally friendly materials
that encourage the natural growth of
coral life
you
British artist Jason de Caire Taylor is
the creative mind and crafter behind
every sculpture each cleverly designed
to also function as an artificial reef
for many years to come he's inspired by
the emotions character and attributes of
the local population balancing
contemporary art and culture with the
dedication to the preservation of nature
thanks to this artistic project The
Dream's collector a man on his
Volkswagen and hundreds of other
sculptures will turn into the home of
thousands of underwater species the
placement of each piece at the bottom of
the Musa has a special purpose there are
sections that have a higher number of
sculptures but they all serve the same
goal to recover the natural reefs while
also providing visitors with a new
attraction water sports like snorkeling
and diving now go hand-in-hand with
fascinating pieces of art the museum is
divided into two galleries salon ranch
owners is an 8 metre deep hall perfect
for divers and swimmers salon near zouk
is 4 meters deep and only suitable for
snorkeling great Mexican talent can also
be admired at Musa which displays works
by Karen Salinas Martinez Roberto Diaz
Abraham Rodrigo quinones Reyes and
Salvador Kira's Ennis among others
visitors from all around the world are
discovering the underwater museum of art
they come to see what's hidden beneath
the waters of the Caribbean
ideal for all ages musa is a wonderful
underwater world that can also be viewed
from glass bottom boats immerse yourself
in a universe of art perfectly combined
with nature in the world's greatest
underwater museum
now if you've ever been in Berlin you've
probably seen a tourist or to navigating
through the city in a somewhat unusual
classic car the trabant or try be as its
affectionately known it's considered the
symbol of communist East Germany where
it was produced the plucky two-cylinder
boxy vehicle survived the fall of the
wall to become a sort of cult object
there are tribes and clubs and countries
around the world including Bulgaria
typical konstantina from Nova TV takes
us for a spin
by the time production of the East
German trabant stopped in 1991 it had
already become a nostalgic icon of the
socialist era new vintage car fans the
world over are restoring old tree bonds
to their former glory or rather a glory
never dreamt of before as with this
one-of-a-kind specimen in panic one
trabant owner says his passion for the
car will never die but he many people
take pictures with cameras and mobile
phones when I Drive past the car is very
attractive but yeah those if told the
cars and I cancer on the streets
probably it's economical and
environmentally friendly those new
regulations forced us to put in a
four-stroke engine this car has been
transformed into a work of art vote race
each quit the PTO the upholstery is made
of vellum and a very modern fabric
called Alcantara it's an outcome that a
brand new dashboard and center console
Imam booth metha the dashboard includes
the temperature and oil pressure gauges
the most elusive but that's not all
Samoa cookie the car xenon headlights
and we've mounted carbon rings for
decoration and as a carbon fibered grill
but I didn't set them and the color is
called royal blue with a little touch of
white on the roof and wheel rims that
gives it a pearly effective effective
federal the overall effect is quite
positive blacks a [ __ ] quick develop
this car gives you a good feeling about
life it's important to have something
different that can give you a positive
outlook
we'll say that this car looks good and
it can actually take you somewhere for
Nova TV i'm jeff kurr Constantino
alright that's it for this edition of
world stories for all of us here in our
partner stations around the world thanks
for watching before we go we'll leave
you with this week's picks of the world
see you next time
you